I have some really shocking news for you
today no I'm kidding I have absolutely
zero percent surprising news which is
that the summit is off the Trump summit
with North Korean leader Kim jong-un has
been canceled he can't cancelled he
canceled it by writing a letter to kim
jeong-hoon where Donald Trump wrote in
part I was very much looking forward to
being there with you sadly based on the
tremendous anger and open hostility
displayed in your most recent statement
I feel it is inappropriate at this time
to have this long planned meeting
therefore please let this letter serve
to represent that the Singapore summit
for the good of both parties but to the
detriment of the world will not take
place it would have been on June 12th
and I think that this is not actually
bad news the idea that Trump would have
been able to handle any kind of real
negotiations is silly if everything was
pre negotiated and Trump's just doing a
handshake okay there was some chance of
what we would call success but Trump
could it easy because we could have
easily ended up doing much more damage
just by his mere presence and it's funny
how from the get-go the Trump is right
was just definitive about the massive
winning that Trump was doing on North
Korea and from day one we knew it was BS
and it would either implode if it
happened or it would simply fall apart
beforehand and it did and it's almost
like there's not that much to add right
it would have been more surprising to me
to see the meeting not canceled and
North Korea recently added that they are
now ready for a nuclear showdown with
the United States if the dialogue fails
and we are right back to where we were
before except possibly in even worse
shape because of this sort of renewed
anger by Trump from being made to look
silly by Kim jong-un I believe and Trump
choosing to cancel this is him just
trying to take control back right and
it's clear that he was clueless from day
one and this is why you know we from the
beginning we said you know Donny boy
other presidents your predecessors knew
better than to agree to these summits
with North Korea without preconditions
maybe they weren't as incompetent as you
made them out to be because every single
move in the last two months has only
precipitated the inevitability
this either failing or falling apart
pulling out of the Iran deal hiring John
Bolton at every level
Trump is has been making mistakes and
the good news is that those
commemorative coins that he had made a
little bit prematurely I'm sure those
will be available at a big discount
outside of Trump Tower soon it'll be a
collector's item before you know it so
no Trump Tower summit I'm sorry no Trump
North Korea summit in Singapore and
we'll see what happens next with North
Korea the video you just finished
watching was made possible by you
through the membership program you can
sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported independent media you
can use the coupon code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership